sleeping around different for men and
for women i don't know i think whatever
people want to do
like if they're sleep if they're if like
a woman's like body count like is higher
than like a guy's like it shouldn't
matter
it matters to a lot of guys though yeah
for some reason it doesn't compete in my
brain as to why it does but they do view
it differently it just held to another
standard where they can sleep with
literally anyone and the minute a woman
does it's like oh well you're a slag or
like there's like the massive discourse
where it's like your vagina gets massive
which is a complete lie because you push
a baby out and then it stretches back so
it's like if you push a baby out and
your vagina can stretch back then why
does it matter how many people you sleep
with like that doesn't change it do you
know what i mean but as a man they can
just go with whoever and it's like oh
you're a lad like that's sick no 100 i
testified to that and i feel like a lot
of like particularly in like this
straight community they and like the
patriarchal ideals are very much like
keep this old like victorian like
ideology where a woman has to be like
virginal to be like attractive i agree
with them no
you don't think so no what about you
society says yes i say no no no i don't
think so so if you were talking to a guy
is there a body count that would be too
high for you to talk to
like if you said i've slept with a
thousand women yeah no it's a no for me
yeah it's you know a thousand women
to be honest you know like how um men
are swimming like how many people have
you slept with that never comes into our
question yeah it's never a thing
because it's like that's your past
that's whatever it is it doesn't really
matter no i think it's uh you view it
differently no no debut differently i
don't know oh right now i don't think i
review it differently if i had the same
body count between a man and a woman i
think it would be like i wouldn't think
anything of it i didn't think no no i
wouldn't so i sleep around a lot i'd be
like as long as you're clean from stds
can i i i do view it differently but
i'll tell you why i'll tell you what
i'll tell you why i'll tell you why
because i think like women have to in
general and i know there's exceptions
but by and large like have to be more
attached and like like a guy more and
it's like easy for a woman to get sex
where guys they have to earn it like a
guy a guy has to be a certain height for
you to be attracted to him he has to be
a certain level of income certain level
of like everything though don't they
not really if you look at the data you
know what percent of the time women
swipe right on dating apps
oh god yeah like women swipe right five
to ten percent of the time where men
swipe right fifty percent
men are like is she hot in there yeah
is she hot there and willing just like
okay you guys are pretty girls right you
go out and you ask ask 10 guys if they
want to have sex you'll get to take her
go get a secret but him it's not going
to be the same if he goes up to 10 10
girls that says do you want to have sex
with me they're going to look at him
like he's nuts or the guys will be like
when and where
but men are probably more likely to do
that though like go up to someone and be
like
hey i don't know yeah i feel like you
have a point with that what's the point
what's the point
i feel like you know let's go after
girls a bit more than girls go after men
and i guess that kind of proves your
point like it's like harder for them to
get like do you know one out of three
men is either a virgin or hasn't had sex
in the past year i really yeah no way i
actually whoa i want to start
feasibility because it's like maybe i
shouldn't i shouldn't be jumping to
conclusions do you think body count
doesn't matter of course no what's your
body count i don't count not that i'm
saying it's a lot roughly only count
roughly
under 20. yeah okay you're more honest
than but everyone tells me virgin no no
because for me it's not like a show-off
thing i'll say oh yeah like it's
something to show off about it's just
like a
you know
guys mostly amongst men like oh yeah
i've slept with this many but with women
it's not that much i think it's more
emotional than physical asking my
question
i would never answer that like even if
god was standing in front of me
even if god was standing in front of me
the only reason i asked that is because
if it doesn't matter what doesn't
everyone just say
like i don't actually i don't actually
care what your body counts are but like
like and so everyone today i asked the
context because then like where is that
gonna go if i'd like to randomly save my
body account like you go anywhere i have
some [ __ ] to say but we can talk about
it after this
it's just interesting you know what i
mean like it's like if it really didn't
matter why don't we all just tell each
other yeah and we do you'll be surprised
i think people do somebody drinks
yeah exactly
would you say that because it's more
emotional for us that sleeping around is
different because we have to have an
emotional connection where men will just
screw anything i mean i don't i can't
speak for all men
in general right for myself like yeah i
think it's more like emotional rather
than just physical yeah if i connect
with you then i connect with you well i
think that's why i think that's why like
men say it's different is because like
we have to like be a ted we have to like
him in some way where a dude can screw a
girl he hates that's it we need to have
some type of physical some kind of
emotional we need to connect in some way
so you kind of understand where they're
coming from a little bit pretty
reasonable if i understand but i i don't
know i can't really answer that okay do
you think body count matters yeah yeah
yes it does yeah why do you think so
many people say it doesn't because
they're liars
because they're capping
would you say your body count
i i don't no no no
no the only reason i ask usually people
will say it doesn't matter and then i'll
ask like what's your body count because
they say it doesn't matter see we're not
liars yeah at least you guys are honest
i don't know if i believe the virgin
thing no i swear i would not mind it
would it wouldn't affect me at all no if
he's the one if he's the one do you guys
believe in the one yeah
i feel like that's like a disney like i
feel like there's just like choices and
trade-offs and you get to like like no
one's there's not one there's not one
person that's like the one i think there
is
so if you're watching put your edgy put
your eyes oh no no no no no no
we got it
we'll find it mate hey come here real
quick
they're fake
come on
[Music]
i know your channels oh yeah um
yeah i thought you were looking at me
earlier
i was like i was like i was like i felt
like he knows who i am i did i did the
question today
is is sleeping around different for men
and for women oh definitely because men
hold no emotional attachment women kind
of like will hold an emotional
attachment if that makes sense so he he
says he says it matters he says it's
different what do you say how's it
different women hold more emotional
attachment like generally if you're if
you were to [ __ ] with a guy you wouldn't
go in it to be like oh yeah i'm just
having sex you're gonna want him to know
you all of that [ __ ] compared to like
i'm just being serious
generalized it's different for everyone
yeah it's different i know there's girls
out there that don't ever like want to
do all that [ __ ] but then majority of
girls would have feelings towards the
guy you're not going to pick up some
random guy that looks like a four of a
five out of ten and just be like yeah
and i'll allow him to smash i think the
question was sorry i'm like taking your
spot as an interviewer the question was
how do you do you see it differently
between men have no like if a guy wants
to mess with a girl he has no emotional
attachment you do see it differently i
generally see most men have no emotional
attachment when it comes to sex okay if
you if me or you wanted to get sex all
we have to do is go around and say
anyone want to have sex we'd have people
lined up if he if he did this right now
he would he's he's a good look he's a
good looking guy if he went he went
around and did that he's sliding in no
no i'm saying i'm saying i'm saying look
at look look i'm just i'm being real
like if he goes around asking girls for
sex they're gonna be like no get the
[ __ ] away from me but me and you me and
you all we have to do is ask
but i personally don't see it different
if a girl told me she has a thousand
bodies so people like a guy that looks
like me
everybody
we should hold like the same standards
that's what you mean yes but like in
reality it's not the same and this yeah
like in reality it's not but the
question was what do i think and i
wouldn't think of a woman less than i do
a man if they have the same body count
as what i was saying
to say this if it's an average looking
guy do you think he would have as much
success to a guy that's way more good
looking in a general sense so for to get
a woman or if he's trying to get her in
bed or relationship status whatever it
is do you think that will happen no but
i think it's the same way with women an
average looking girl and an average girl
would have a better chance with any type
of guy she would want i'm just gonna i'm
just gonna put this in perspective i i
consider myself average i literally do
i've no no i know girls will always
correct me but like i'm just being real
like i feel like most people are normal
looking and i feel like i'm normal
looking and i've had i've had nba
players slide in my dms
that's it it's not it's not a flex it's
not a flex they're looking it's not it's
not look at look at that we're not gonna
look at like we're not gonna i'm saying
i'm saying like that's not a flex though
they're just looking for easy sex and so
i'm saying like that would never happen
like to a guy where like a blue check
mark girl is gonna slide in his dms of
just a normal guy